okay hi everyone welcome to what for me
is the third live stream of the day uh
wolfen language design review part of
our language completeness and
consistency series
and our first topic is the highlighted
function
right so uh right so highlighted was
this nice little
you know typeset generator to you know
highlight things
and then apparently you recently decided
that you'll reuse it for
the plot stuff yep and I you know don't
like it yes okay
um
you want to look at highlighted new
capital n e w
yep Capital all caps just the n
all right
oh boy
right so you right so we have these sort
of two
right so the one argument form I guess
I suppose could make sense in either
although how it formats
you know on its own would not be related
to
the the effects it causes when it's used
inside of a plotting function
and I don't know what if anything we
should do with the two argument form
when it's uh
you know when it's outside of a vis
function I mean I suppose we could do
nothing with it and just sort of let it
okay the the issue is
and this is the 13 3 issue right
yes um
we've got this whole giant system
I mean you know we've got labeled
for example
is also something which is a a joint
you know visualization and
expression formatting type function
right is it I mean it is and we've never
added the viz stuff to the docs for the
label that's all lives on Vis Pages oh
gosh that's a terrible thing that's
really terrible that's really
embarrassingly bad
yeah labeled is absolutely available in
both places
okay
yes and is okay I guess I didn't
entirely grok that we already had this
issue
uh
I think we only have it with the tooltip
don't we as well
yeah well I guess except that it's sort
of I mean there there's a much more
direct relationship I mean with both
labeled and tooltip right there's a much
more direct relationship between what's
there and what's
uh
well I mean here's one that probably
should work and doesn't
right that should work and what should
that be that should be I mean if we say
list plot
table call out
that does that right
okay I'll buy so you're saying that call
out on its own should create a graphics
box and and no I think call out on its
own should do like what label does or
you know if I say label the framed or
whatever right which I do all the time
um you know the idea of having a call
out that is a little pointer to
something and that has you know I can
imagine in a mathematical expression for
example wanting to point to something in
that expression and say you know the big
term or whatever
right except you can't really point the
thing outside of a graphics box well but
you can in the same way you can label it
you can have a little stalk that comes
out of it that says four for example
I I well I mean uh
right as a practical matter I don't
think you can have that
how
right how I mean how do those you know
how does that non-rectangular shape get
created
right no I'm I'm saying the following
just like with labeled here okay let's
say I put in labeled with this thing
saying you know top right
mm-hmm
I don't know why rate didn't work why
didn't write well maybe it's right who
says it didn't work
what happens if I say
scaled
I don't even know right I mean just make
X bigger
xxxx
okay okay yeah
yeah okay all right so that's a
potential bug but but my point is
that to put a little stalk here and to
have it like a thought bubble call out
does not seem out of the question
and that will be the analog of this
right and probably what we should do
by the way another thing which is maybe
a little bit like this is button
uh uh so it it it doesn't really make a
difference with buttons arguments but
like button has an appearance option but
if you use button in a graphic the
appearance option is basically ignored
it doesn't you know it's it doesn't look
like a system button you can't make it
look like a system button
what does it look like well uh here let
me just uh
um
throw an example in the chat
yeah if you inset a button it'll look
like a button but if you wrap a button
around Primitives it'll look like The
Primitives
oh I switched this thing yeah yeah right
you just have it is a buttoned area
yeah
so
for a standalone button you would have
expected the whole button to have a
certain appearance but in graphics that
appearance option is just ignored
right so to me
I mean this really is arguing that the
the combined use of highlighted is not
that stupid
mm-hmm
and now the question would be
if there's an effect
in
you know if you say
right so if you if you do expert comma
you know drop lines and it's not in the
graphics it's not in a vis function then
I don't know what yeah the appearance
isn't going to do anything here
it's the other way around I mean in
um and similarly
are you saying it should look like the
one argument form
or are you saying it just shouldn't
format so if I if I do right so I have
highlighted a foo there now underneath
it right highlighted of Foo comma you
know drop lines yeah what should the
output look like should it look like the
input two lines above it or should it uh
look looking yeah
okay I think yes I mean I think that
um
I mean this is a graphics question I'm
not sure maybe somebody has a better
idea
Maybe
I mean this is a non-coordinatized
let's see what's the point here
uh
I mean it's a little bit
unfortunate that highlighted
in the visualization case doesn't do
anything until you're interior mousing
near it
is that true or is that
I mean it has the static ones with
placed which are broken at the moment
somehow but
um what static ones
listed on this rough page there's a
basic example in the highlighted page
that third example
right although again six would be
completely meaningless
in yeah same outside yeah
right
so right so so maybe the answer is these
don't format outside of that maybe the
two arc form doesn't format outside of
uh
outside of this functions or at least we
we at least not for 13 3 and if we
decide to tweak that in the future we
will leave the door open to that but
yeah
I could imagine you know at some point
us coming up with some coordinate system
for
you know the Expressions whether it's
parts and taxes or something else
and that we do have you know
things that become available
right
yeah so it's not right so I mean
right the the other question that sort
of the result of the meeting a couple
weeks ago right because right now and I
don't think we've changed this yet right
if you
if right if you take the the formatted
highlight and use it as input uh the the
head goes away
um
and right the highlighted head goes away
right so if you take that output that
yellow Foo
or and you know use that as input
that'll just turn into a foo on output I
think that's a mistake right and well I
guess there there are I mean there are
two questions I think one I think one of
them is basically answered by the fact
that
um
by the fact that we're giving it this
new meaning which it was you know how
important was it that this round trip
exactly and you know preserve the head
highlighted as opposed to be becoming a
style thing and it sounds to me like the
answer is we need this to perfectly
round trip or yeah we're we're losing
yeah we're toast
um the second question is
um does strip on input mean anything
in the viscase
you know strip on input is an
interesting option for labeled which we
don't have right now
correct I hadn't even thought of that
would be a good option to have that
where the stripping would take
everything but the payload payload
or should we have a a kind of a a um an
auto wrapper
or does that not make sense
um
no it doesn't make sense because you
have to know what function you're in to
know what to strip
I think
I mean unless all it's doing is taking
the first element on input
see what I'm saying I mean if you have
um
and that that actually is interpreted as
first of expert
for example
or even we could have something which
says um
input stripped
F comma X bar
input applied
kind of interesting
F comma X bar which then I think you
want the option
well can somebody comment on this idea
of an input applied wrapper that applies
a function or maybe we already have this
I think we have this I think this is
dynamic setting
my gosh
I thought we must have this
there are no new ideas it turns out and
this no but I agree that this looks very
similar
yeah this is the same thing this is the
same idea
but I think yeah I think extending strip
on input to more
you know more of these sort of fancy
generators would make sense yes
um I think the other thing that's coming
is being able to have labeled inside
Graphics which I'd really like to see
happen
um
okay
any more to say about this particular
issue look look by the way that thing
there
which for some reason I understand why
there's an additional call out on that
on that thing beyond the call out that
there already is but
anyway that thing is the quintessential
kind of static call out type thought
level thing
right but I'm I will I mean that that I
believe works because it's inside of a
graphics box
right and and and and so you know I'm
just not sure if we're in a purely texty
world even that 2D texty world I don't
know how we get something that looks
like that unless we have just or some
sort of static icon that we stick in or
something yeah that's what I think we
should do I mean I think we should have
a thing that looks like that
that is a call out that looks like that
it has a you know a thought bubble type
thing but it's just you know it's like
it's always there
like there it is you know
except there's not a DOT there there's
an X there or something
it's a perfectly nice form I mean it
will be perfectly useful to say you know
I've got this list of terms and one of
them you know I've got list one two
three four
you know and just like I can say of this
one
framed for example
it's useful to do that so it'll be
useful to have a call out from that one
I don't think it's very difficult to
build I think we just haven't haven't
built it
all right anything else on this topic
um
um right so I get we we didn't actually
answer the question of the strip on
input in any way impact
the how viz functions treat these things
or do they just ignore it for now
they mostly ignore it I mean
you currently have the ability to go
from the output of plot back to the
original input of plots right you know
so you don't have a round trip to start
with and so
okay and and and so it'll just be an
option that might be present and it will
completely ignore it yep
okay
that's fine
I mean well fine is maybe too strong a
word but it's a it's something I'm
perfectly willing to live with
exactly
okay all right are we on to the next
topic yep
emphasis underlying Style
right so at one point squiggled What's
called emphasized and you suggested
renaming under light right which is the
front-end sub option
as emphasis underline Style
but I don't think given that we've gone
away from emphasized I don't think that
this name
still makes sense what are we calling
this this thing now under light it's a
font variations what are we calling the
rapper oh squiggled
it's called squiggled
yep
[Music]
well it's fun at least oh I mean we had
a huge discussion about this there were
many Alternatives and this was by far
the best one
yeah I think I think we've spent a total
of you know probably 90 minutes over at
least two meetings again
so so go back and view the archives yeah
okay the okay
um
well why isn't this just called
squiggled
but because it takes uh at least for the
moment it takes a color and one could
conceive that in the future it might
take maybe some other uh styling things
like a like a thickness
what is it again
oh Sub sub option for font variation
yeah
I'll call it squiggle Style
okay I mean that that was bullet point
number you know option number one under
the three options but we just want it
you know since we didn't want to have to
rename it a second time we wanted to you
you to actually sign off on this okay
fine by me
right so right you didn't like the fact
that uh right that had pushed so we have
this thing is that actually
one is this prototype build from I don't
know that that doesn't look like
him
yeah you need a 13-4 prototype giving me
a thirteen four prototype you know I
only have what I'm given all right well
then that's I don't know what we do in
this in this okay so listen I have this
set of icons okay I'm running that icon
there if we are at a moment in time when
I need five icons
I I forget you know we do go through
this
yeah
with the Prototype build it just we're
not doing 13-3 prototype builds anymore
it just cut over to thirteen four so you
don't need to like keep a 13-3 archive
or something
okay but then why is this wrong
because it cut over to 13 4 and that
happened seldom enough that the scripts
probably have not been fixed to to deal
with that
um possibility oh
oh okay well so do I have to see
somebody else's screen yeah let me
just um
join from
this is the
oh wow we're in some completely new
meeting
um
I
I'm not sure that the machine I'm
currently sitting at
uh is
this doesn't
okay just tell me roughly what I'm gonna
see yeah so so here you can let me share
now okay you can grab the show directly
from me I think
are you it says it says
okay and uh
okay and
right so
right so we right you didn't like the
fact that it pushed down the stuff so
now you see it doesn't push anything
down
um now
where is your mouse I don't know where
your mouse is oh I uh you can't the map
so right so right now my mouse is to the
right of the data set okay and you can
see from the cursor that the line height
is exactly equal to the visible data set
then when I bring it when it's sort of
just over the elements then you see this
empty white box which I don't like so
much
um
right I don't know if this is wasn't
entirely clear to me if this is uh a
Missy if this was something with how so
Ian told me that there was it was
difficult to get rid of this for some
reason it wasn't entirely clear to me if
this was sort of how Chris Carlton
structured the code or if it's something
about the attached cell that we don't
understand yet the the former I think
okay right so all right so then right
but if it's if you sort of gener right
when you see one and I'm directly over
an element it gives sort of the index of
that element and so we should so I guess
we should be able to make it so that it
doesn't appear until you're actually
over the elements the current
functionality have different
functionality from that
no it's the same functionality so what
do I want to copy something other than
the
uh well then you right click on it and
you copy I see
right you can see your mouse now
ah okay I don't know what did that it
just disappeared again
well I'm here I'm going to the different
Mathematica here just
right so
it's right so we added the frame I think
I believe that was something you
requested
um
and yeah and the behavior is the same so
um other right only this one only this
one right is taller than right there's
extra space so so the only difference
here is the fact that it is being
extruded below the thing which I think
is the right thing has somebody from
design opined about that frame
about which frame
so we need that
okay but which frame are we talking
about the little ghost frame oh the
ghost frame okay yeah so no we yeah we
were like I said see how I highlight if
I how I put rough in bold
you know uh right I mean it could be
that actually having a a reversed out
color for that thing like I don't know I
don't know what's better but we need
some design input okay
um I think that can be given the
constraint that we have to have the box
I I bet that can be handled in the
design if it's true we have to have the
box I bet that the design can be such
that that isn't too horrifying
it might even be good
all right so then the the one of the
things we didn't uh consider last time
is what to do in the case where we have
the store now button
so when we sort of naively just always
attached the you know the the little
extruding thing at the bottom then it
would appear sort of down here in the
white space and that was really bad
um what to do right I mean you want it
to appear in that space where your mouse
is right now right well I I was worried
that that my that they might crash into
each other
um
and uh well that's why you have a box
around it and the unlikely event of a of
a
uh crash
then let it overwrite and just be an
inclusion on top of the other thing
because I think it'll be very very very
rare that they crash and if they crash
it'll be very obvious why they're
crashing and that thing is ephemeral and
it's you know it's not um
I don't think it's horrifying okay and
uh right I mean we'll need to sort of
uh uh I guess because that's the reason
when when you tell design folk about it
you need to tell them that there is a
possibility unlikely event of a crash
okay and therefore the bordering must
work in that case which I think is not
problematic
okay
um
okay and I kind of think in the case
where if indeed you have to have that
box when there's nothing in it I kind of
think having a little Dash there or
something might be good
okay
um
all right so I guess that's
um I guess I did have sir well I I can
ask John offline I think I have a couple
of sort of technical questions about the
implementation but I don't think we need
to have that discussion right here okay
all right am I sharing again yep
okay what's next
is another question about
uh Max about data set which is this Max
item settings
so if you I right I hear I gave a list
of uh
you know three threes so at every level
I see
right I see three planets three moons
Etc
um
then or I can give it a list of one
thing so I get you know three three
moons but then if I mean three planets
but then I get more than three moons yep
um so the question is what should Max
items goes to just a naked three
do like I understand
what's that I understand the question
okay so according to the documentation
it does the second thing
um and I'm just raising yeah
right I'm not uh
uh I'm just sort of raising the question
because when we first saw this
we were confused by this and this does
have the disadvantage of there's no way
to just say
Max items goes to you know use the same
with we following this interpretation
there's no way to say use three items at
every level you'd have to manually
construct a list of the correct number
of Threes maybe that's not worth
changing that hold on the fact that it
shows that there is an illusion makes
this a much softer decision
okay
well it's not like you're cutting it off
for the take or something
I think there's a decent argument that
if you say Max items as three
that you're basically trying to restrict
the size
and that you'll be annoyed if somehow
you know some bizarre planet has 700
moons and blows up your data set
yep
so I mean I'm tentatively saying I think
the default
uh
where
it's that number at all levels makes
more sense to me
anybody want to violently disagree with
that oh I'll just add an interesting but
not useful for today aside that uh uh
one might consider a specification sort
of like what we were talking about for
grid where you have you know some notion
of uh you know maybe a cyclic rapper
that you could uh that you could put in
there
we should return to this when we look at
grid
wait a minute which one does it do right
now does it do right
right now
no it does the second one I think it
should do the first one
okay
okay next stop
so this is the John and Lou show so I
will let them uh so this particular one
is much more the lusso
right so the notebook history palette
has been a thorn on our side for audio
is very odd talking of thorns
uh
you sound yeah
electronically challenged
Lou if you're talking now we don't hear
you at all
okay any better yes okay
um so right the so you have a prototype
build and you can look and see what
we've done as a possible replacement for
Notebook history so next next to menu in
um cell menu next to notebook history
there is a new menu item notebook
history details
which opens a
live notebook that lets you investigate
you know it's sort of pre-populated with
some inputs that lets you dig into the
history and other aspects of the
notebook that was foremost when you
selected that menu item
um and the new function that it calls
cell data is a thing that produces
a data set of information about cells in
the given notebook
okay so if you evaluate that first input
the result will be a data set that
includes things like
the change times the byte count of every
cell
um you know any options that literally
is set in any cell
Etc let me ask this question before we
before we get too far into this there's
a cell ID nowadays right
yeah
I have this feeling that giving the
literal content here is going to cause
trouble
because
it might change well maybe I'm wrong
no
no actually uh
the the cell uuids are stable
oh these aren't The UU IDs they are
oh really okay then I'm good I mean we
don't show it because it would be kind
of s meaningless to display
but but it is in the input form
okay and you can get the data I mean so
this what we're seeing now are the
pieces of information that are chosen by
default
but you can ask specifically for any
option or any current value on the cells
and that includes the expression uid so
you can get the expression uid as part
of the visible data in this data set if
that's
okay right yes and don't be confused by
cell ID versus expression uuid
okay so once we have this data which one
is which this is a cell ID right yeah so
cell ID is the is is a non-unique number
that sort of has been manually assigned
to a cell in a notebook
that's the old thing the expression uuid
is the unique but you like this
that's the expression uid okay great
yeah a cell ID is a thing we added like
back in 2000 and I know shows its age
right
okay this is a lovely thing I mean this
seems highly useful
right and then the question is you know
do we do we show people how to educate
people about what they can do with this
so the next few inputs show some
examples of what one can do and the
input you just evaluated is the thing
that that comes close with built-in
functions comes closest to the old
history view that uh
that we used to show in the dialogue
yeah but I mean the history of you from
the dialogue
has it had some other features like
linking back to the original cell
that is that would be missing here
well I mean which we could add in fact
we could add we could build I mean
that's that's part of the question is
what what are the interesting things we
want to provide and maybe they're wfrs
built on top of this data maybe they're
built-in things yeah I mean I have to
say I I found the whole thing so finicky
I mean I find it useful to see
the most important thing is the
windowing and I guess Brett is here and
the truth is
that you know that's a feature that we
should add to list plot that's the next
big thing that we should add in terms of
interactive graphics features
it's changing the plot range and zooming
in and yeah yep yeah
I mean that's the only thing we need to
have this be as functional as the thing
that was you know
where's the there's a zooming and
there's also the linking and linking is
not implemented here linking in other
words I understand okay you could do
with the call out or something like that
you could do a linking if you really
wanted to I don't think that's
um
right I mean these things here just seem
to me like the documentation of you know
that part of the documentation of
well this is a completely different
thing there but I mean in um
they're part of the documentation of the
cell data
right this is this is presented in this
way just so that it's in the menu
somewhere like the notebook history
stuff was in the menu somewhere yeah
more like a I think we make some picture
I mean you're only suggesting that this
be there
as a matter of compatibility because
otherwise you just tell people use the
function
sure
um
I mean we could also have cell data
directly produce this If This Were
thought to be an interesting
visualization
uh it's okay I mean
yes it is I mean we could have a nice
visualization that is produced by
um
look I love cell data here this is
exactly the kind of thing we need
um
and so essentially what you're doing
here is this is the thing I've been
wanting for millions of years that's
just a proper computable version of this
now what does it do
for example does this actually have the
contents of the cell in this data set if
we'd understood you've been weighing
this for a million years we would have
given it to you uh a million years minus
a week or two
so Stephen it might be useful I've
written some draft documentation for
cell data it lives in the wires system
if and there's a link to it in that uh
in yes right there
so the answer to your question is the
data is not there by default but you can
summon any data that you want in any
calls or something that's good that it's
not there by default because otherwise
I'm worrying about you know gigabyte
size notebooks right so pop open the
details and options section and you'll
see the list of
the uh of some of the optional things
that we can include okay so if I say
okay so let me just right and the the
cell objects should be clickable right
they're still clickable to select the
the the the cell that it's referring to
so it's easy to get to the cell
from the cell object okay but so if I
say something like
um
uh comma
so this doesn't return a data set this
returns a list uh because you've given a
single thing if that single thing were
within a list
then you would have gotten a data set
back instead I don't know what that
error is but
that's great
it's that single thing I'm sorry if the
single thing here what so the second if
the second argument is a single token
you get a list the second argument is a
list of tokens even if it's a list of
one token you'll get back a data set
and you can specify multiple token I
mean you can say you can ask for the
thumbnail and is this what we do in
entity lookups or not
we should do whatever we do in entity
lookups
do entity lookups return data sets by
default not by default well so uh now
you have to explicitly ask for a data
set yeah so that may be the wrong thing
here okay so let's just walk through
this again for a second
Okay so
the default thing
um
is to return a data set with certain
standard things in it right but you have
various other things you can produce
correct
and and you can specify lists of them
yeah so so we went up with the data set
including the thumbnail and the full
cell expression and other things
yeah I mean this is what we should have
done a really long time ago guys I mean
this is
this is both very nice and um
uh so the moment you have a data set it
it gives you it uses the cell object as
a key
yes by default you can there are there
are ways to tweak that
why was this compatibly slow this
particular one
um I'm not sure I think it's because
first change time is actually a
calculated
thing that that coerces the the storage
format for these is
for these change times are absolute time
and I'm coercing them to to date objects
so that's you know that times 100
that's no biggie hey look it was a short
time I think it was just some
initialization thing
uh
these Should Be Strings
to go in line with other stuff we have
which has data set
sort of thing I think we should also
support this probably
okay so maybe the thing for me to do is
to move this function if we're happy
with the cell data name for now no we're
not hold on okay talk about that yet
okay
I'm very happy with the functionality
the basic functionality
and we call this cell information
because or something like that because I
mean cell data that sounds like
something on par with you know box data
yeah right which is not what what we
want to evoke
what other information functions do we
have well we do have a cell information
function in the developer uh context
we've also migrated most of the
information functions into the function
information
[Music]
yeah I mean actually in principle what
cell information is doing now probably
ought to move to information
well then we call her both information
about a cell and cell information
right
all right but the point is that this
even by default
your concept is
it's a bit of a bizarre default
well the point is it can be self-focused
not just notebook Focus you can give it
a collection of cell objects and get the
data for all of them
right
whether we want the zero argument form
to point out a cell object or a notebook
object I don't I don't feel strongly
about
um
I think it's more useful to point to the
whole notebook
I think that single cell is kind of like
okay and it's and it's consistent with
what cells does
open close yes
all right let me just see what are we
going to call this so
this is very Cellular in the sense that
its keys are always cell objects is that
a true statement
it's
um the raw data for the keys is always
cell objects there is currently an
option that lets one change the key its
key function is the name of the option
and it takes the cell object and
produces whatever key you want from it
um okay
uh
you can see examples of it in the draft
docs if you care too but it's still
but that computed key started life
being computed from a cell object still
right in the options of the thing it
always cells are the
what could we call it cell information
is just too confusing because it's so
similar to information
it's all data set
cell query
no
I assume this can't just be part of
information
well information doesn't return data
sets right that returns
it returns uh decorated associations
more or less yeah I mean it's it's uh
it's a what what is it information data
which is a wrapper around
uh
uh an association a wraparound
Association and gifts
on that
what's so different about this
well I mean the keys the keys of of of
uh information data thing are
are you know typically
you know the properties not not
well this thing has keys that are
properties too they just
I mean in the okay
right I mean I guess
we could maybe play around with that
um
object to mean something different I
mean it's not clear that we want this
mm-hmm
um
right information tends to be more
summary-ish than you know exhaustive yes
or meta which this is
let's see
cell details
no I think it sounds like an option
um cell structure
it's not the structure of the cells
notebook structure makes more sense
but then we would expect something more
like text structure which is something
do we have that from notebook import can
we get a graph of The Notebook
of the tree structure of the notebook
um
there's nothing baked in
to notebook Imports notebook trees seems
like it's the kind of another kind of
tree that would be worth having
yes
I believe expression tree has
undocumented support for Notebook
okay I think it should be a separate
thing
okay so what is this doing this is
saying
you've got
a notebook object
I mean a name like notebook cell data
which is very close to what you have
with your context
doesn't seem totally terrible
because it's of a notebook
what do people think of that I just
don't like cell data it's just too
yeah what do you guys think about this
having notebook and cell feels a little
bit weird
but it's what it is I know I'm just wow
it's not always what it is I mean you
could have a list of cell objects which
might not be in the same notebook I it's
a weird use case but it's technically
possible
they are notebook cells however not
biological cells or other any other kind
of cell
um
what do we call
yeah it's system process data
it's kind of the most analogous thing I
can think of
yes
I mean I suppose I I I I I mean I
suppose the most accurate name would be
cell objects data
I think that's incomprehensible I think
people will think about it just like
we've had a notebook history thing
what about something in about notebook
history
I mean it's way more than that but yeah
it is it is confusing
notebook contents data
I mean this is specifically ignoring
notebook options there's no way to get
notebook options out of this thing
yeah and it's also kind of ignoring them
it's grinding up the content
into I mean notebook content data might
be much more like to summarize this
notebook llm
I I
should we be dismissing cell object data
that's really not obviously silly to me
object singular
yeah
well I I mean I suggested I suggested
the plural but
I mean because in fact it it can only
work on
cell objects either directly or derived
from an up from a notebook object
I mean I have to say I like notebook
cell data because I think it connects
with the most common use case which is
notebooks
it connects with the notebook history
story
um
to go soon but
I favor notebook cell data
I think it's the right level of
complexity of name for what the function
is
now in terms of the design of the
function itself
uh the formats are a third argument or
something or what
correct
okay I think it should be a quoted thing
except for automatic obviously
now and I I'm I'm a little unclear what
we're moving towards I mean it should be
said that you know just in terms of
having this in a wfr you know the with
the what we've talked about so far I
mean that's that can be done in very
short order if you're talking about
action creating new systems simple of
course that would be uh into the next
release
it should be in the next two weeks which
are wfr in this release and system
symbol in the next release okay
and
those key functions normalized dates
obviously we don't really like the
string
oh is there something we can reuse for
both of those
there must be a date format function
date format
option
yeah there is a date format option for
data object
okay
so to be clear
this doesn't just change format it
changes the expression that gets stored
um right
and without normalizing you get the raw
data that this front-end has stored
which I think is just the absolute time
spec
you know what I really don't care about
that I think we should use our data
object
and if they're not efficient enough we
should make them more efficient we've
been doing a lot of work on that
recently and there will be any more in
the next version but yeah that going
from absolute times to the data objects
it just doesn't seem useful to have
absolute times it just seems like a you
know
just a mess
so you're suggesting removing the option
and always doing the transformation
that's what I'm suggesting yes
I'm fine now the keys is there's some
function we get is there an option we
can use from somewhere else for the keys
[Music]
well I think that's a by the way it
should surely say identity there the key
function
other than
uh
once this column headings will always be
strength in the elements specified as a
symbol what does that mean so the
elements the second argument contains a
list of the things that you want those
things might be option names which can
be symbols like font size font color oh
but in the generated data set
those things are always you know as far
as doing data set lookups that's
sensible
I didn't understand the the fact that
you could ask for this so if I if I do
that
if I say here
uh wherever it is
[Music]
um
can I do Style
oh it's called cell Style
but what about the the base style of the
other thing
what's that called
I think that's cell style name
sorry John
um
wait yeah
looks like it
that's cool it's
not something that I would have
guaranteed would have worked so right I
tie into current values in this as well
John just you know so current values
that apply to cell object can also be
used as tokens in this
second argument
Okay so
look these things like key function I
mean I I will we have uh we there's
labeling function I mean it's a bit of a
what is Library function what's it uses
no you don't want that
right that's uh I mean that's used by
Vis functions for
I think there's something we've had
that's like this but you know what you
could pack these things if you want to
systemize this you could pack these into
a method option both of these you could
include them you could say method arrow
and then key function Arrow blah blah I
mean Group by has a way of doing this
but it's not and you know it's a syntax
it's not an option name right
I think this is an obscure thing
honestly
because many things you'll do will have
collisions
you see what I'm saying
yeah getting something unique this is
the unique thing basically
Lou do you have other what else might
you imagine for keys so there's a
there's a there's examples down in the
options section I think I guess because
the obvious one would be you know using
the actual ID the uuid or just maybe so
there's one that coerces to a uid and
then there's one that coerces to just
index
um that's kind of funky
I mean I'm I'm wondering whether
you know it is something like you know
nearest where
you give your list of properties that
you want and then Arrow
you know I want the uuid or I want
indexed or
well it'll be indexed Arrow probably
again I don't think this is terribly
important why don't we put in a method
option for now and if it turns out to be
significant
uh
uh yeah I just don't think it's going to
be terribly important because I think
telling cells by number
you know we finally after 35 years we
added line numbers
to package editing so far raw cell
numbers have not been a thing
I'm not making sense
yeah
probably they won't become so this is
nice work by the way Lou this is a good
thing
um
all right the other stuff that we want
to talk about here
that's cool
that is quite cool
well so so we've talked about the system
symbol the question remains what we do
with the menus if anything if we just
remove the notebook history item
entirely and educate people in some
other way or we replace it with
something that
attempts to educate on this front
um
go ahead I I think we've agreed
previously that we would remove the menu
item once we had a suitable kernel
replacement
and that certainly would be my
preference
the the the thing at point of view that
I'm buying menu item has become
something of an albatross
yeah
we should do another review of the menus
particularly in the land of LMS and
things like that oh you always want to
do reviews of menus
that's like your favorite two years
every few years
it's um
and and then when we actually do the
reviews you you focus on one thing and
then you just get bored
okay lots of strategy
um
uh
we could put it in I mean you know
notice that we could also do this in the
cloud now
which you haven't been able to do before
yeah that's true
what can we now do in the cloud I'm
sorry run all this notebook history
stuff
ah
it's the the kinds of things that Lou is
doing uh I'm not sure if every last
thing is supported by the cloud but most
of it is pretty Elementary stuff in
terms of cloud support
right Okay so
hmm
I don't know I'd be curious to know
whether people in our community and
elsewhere have been using notebook
history I don't know I mean I use it
occasionally but I'd be perfectly happy
with these functions
I primarily use it to make sure I've
successfully removed all cell changed
times from my notebook before I
committed to Version Control oh
well okay
that's a different issue and we should
have a wfr to do that
as you say I use the cell statistics
part of it more than the history parts
what cell statistics
the part that's closed by default the
number of number of cells size of cells
yeah and Brett cares because he's you
know composing documentation and doesn't
want you know to accidentally have some
gigantic thing make its way into the
documentation yeah I mean I wanted that
I didn't even know it was closed now I
remembered it from past years just to
get a sense of I mean I don't know how
big okay an unsaved notebook how do you
know how big it is
um
the I mean
the
does does the notebook history give that
to you or does it give you the memory
size might give you the the in memory
gives you the memory size yeah which is
also useful
um
yeah by the way we could have a notebook
memory and use function
so there I mean there are ways to get
what you're asking for it's not
incredibly cheap
you know I mean it's not going to be
updating every time you modify the
notebook uh yeah I understand but I just
said I just sang I think a notebook
memory and use function does seem quite
useful
does memory use work I mean it works on
what dollar front end but does it
uh yes but uh is that documented
I think I think so yes uh but I know I
do but we don't
we're not keeping track of things on a
notebook by notebook basis and there is
a lot of stuff that is right you know
styles that are sharing between
notebooks yeah all right because that's
a hard thing to compute yeah well I mean
can you compute it on request or not
well I mean what we can compute easily
is uh uh things that you know the the
raw data of the notebook and how much uh
how much is consuming what we can't
compute easily is the the kind of
metadata style type stuff
because that's the stuff that gets
shared right
okay
well all right so look the
why don't we have an explanatory
notebook for now under notebook history
but I mean this is all 13-4 anyway
right
but the wfr is now and we just have it
okay
yeah
and in terms of this getting how much
memory I mean
the storage size of a notebook would be
a useful thing to be able to easily get
that's what I mostly want I don't want
the number of Graphics cells and this
and that and the other I just well
actually what I would like
probably is the story yeah I mean it's
it's basically you know string length of
export string you know to The Notebook
format
I understand but that might be huge and
I mean I guess the two questions I would
ask are
uh how big is The Notebook altogether if
I save it on disk and where are the big
contributors to that
so I'm saying is that yeah well so I
just answered your first question the
second question is
uh well your first the answer you gave
might be undoable
because the answer might be 50 gigabytes
yeah
no no uh
string length of export string to
to notebook of you know of evaluation
notebook
um I know but I mean I mean I mean it's
it's basically what it's going to do is
it's going to call the front end and say
act like you're saving but instead of
saving to a file save to a string which
gets sent back to the kernel
I know but that's a lot of I mean that's
a lot of footwork for something that is
potentially
well yeah but but but that's on the way
yeah I mean that that's the only way
that you can know
uh how big it's going to be on disk is
to at least pretend to save it
as an export string or export byte count
look at this this is not exactly the
speediest thing in the world
and this is not a complicated notebook
data sets are big data sets use a lot of
boxes
yeah
and it's spinning and I I would say this
is a flop
ah my god there was a flashing Ike
dialog box
it's spinning and dying if there were an
efficient way to get the
serialized length of a string expression
John
we could add that as an accessor in this
new function
so if you get a Cell by cell I mean I
mean we we do have
a mechanism in the front end to
um
to pretend to serialize without actually
serializing anywhere and the purpose of
that is back when uh storage media were
smaller and you could run out of disk
space on your your floppy disk or your
you know Zip drive or whatever
um uh before we would overwrite an
existing file we would you know kind of
run through the entire file counting the
bytes and see if we had enough bytes
left are we still doing that yes
is that what the original saving
you know
checking checking yes is that what
that's doing
yeah
um and I I sorry I haven't been paying
attention to the to the messaging I
don't remember what correlates with what
messaging
um
but we're not doing something which is
going to waste time in Saving a big
notebook are we well it's uh uh it
consumes a little time but compared to
the actual writing it's it's quite small
we better check this because when I see
checking it often is takes a long time
relative to saving
that's a so but something to understand
is that there is prep work that goes
into saving and that prep work needs to
be done even before the byte county is
saying that this notebook is 511
kilobytes on the file system yet it's
here 1.5 megabytes according to this
well you've been making changes to it
not many I've been saving most of the
time
I mean let's see if we say notebook file
what is it called notebook file
what is it a notebook file name notebook
file name yeah
okay boom
yep
okay I mean I mean Avery's probably
looking at through Dropbox and maybe it
hasn't updated through Dropbox yet oh
yeah okay fine
okay anything else we need to cover here
should probably look at this fine okay
for today so okay so thirteen four the
plan would be to have a notebook history
thing that points as Lou has it more or
less off to an explanatory notebook
that right
but we might let's let's revisit that
decision when we actually have this
thing in the system okay and and
notebook cell data was the name we
agreed on I think so or before uh
varying definitions of agreed yeah I
think that's right
okay good stuff very nice we got through
the agenda well done and uh talk to you
all soon
bye okay bye